JONATHAN ZITTRAIN:
Well, good evening.
Hello.
My name is Jonathan
Zittrain, and I
am so pleased to be
here with you all today
to hear from John Palfrey on
the occasion of the release
of his book, BiblioTech-- Why
Libraries Matter More Than
Ever in The Age of Google.
Nicely focused group to get
Google in there, as well.
It's very nice, a
googleable term.
JOHN PALFREY: It's all SEO.
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN: Yes.
First just logistics--
this is being recorded.
So your image, if not soul, are
being captured for posterity.
It is not being live
webcast, but it will probably
go up later unless something
truly substantively
catastrophic happens.
And what else should we know?
We're going to go into around
7:00, 7:15, at which point
there will be a reception
next door that can also
spill over onto
the outdoor patio,
to which everybody is invited.
And John has done about
a dozen talks so far
on the road for this
book, so our challenge
is to ask him questions
that he has yet
to hear from the road,
which is very exciting.
He's spoken to a group as
small as about 30 or 40
at the Andover Bookstore,
and as big as 1,000
at a conference called
Computers and Libraries?
JOHN PALFREY: Yes, that was.
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN:
Good eponymous title,
a solid non-focused group--
Computers and Libraries.
They ought to alternate every
year, Libraries and Computers.
Anyway.
JOHN PALFREY: I'll send
them that suggestion.
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN:
Yes, very good.
So how to introduce John?
John is a lawyer-- that gets
a chortle through the room.
But that's OK, he's an
unpracticing lawyer,
unless you think of practicing
in the larger sense.
Now, he did do a turn
at Ropes and Gray
before being rescued
by the Berkman Center.
JOHN PALFREY: I was
there almost as long
as Yochai Benkler,
who is also here.
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN: Ah.
I forget that Yochai also
did a turn at Ropes and Gray.
Good times.
But John worked for the EPA
for a while, regional office.
You were kind of in a
political sort of role, yes?
Anything more you want
to tell us about the EPA?
JOHN PALFREY: Nope.
[LAUGHTER]
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN: As you can
see, it was a political role.
And John was Executive
Director of the Berkman Center
and was the one who really
put the center into workdrive
and took it from a kind of
small place in a hallway
to a larger place that met fire
codes much better than it did
before, and that really had
an inclusiveness to his way
of running the place that has
been reflected in the substance
that he has thought about
since, a book on interop
and interoperability.
And this in a way is a
book about interoperability
and thinking about
the mortar that
cements the various
bricks we have together
in ways that keep civil society.
That's so much, I think,
of what John thinks about.
And of course, day to
day now, after having
done a turn as a
professor here, director
of the library here at
the law school, and now
is the head of school at
Phillips Andover, which
he is in the process completely
reinventing and doing
all sorts of cool things
which we might hear about.
So John is just
one of these people
who is not a podium thumper,
doesn't shout to be heard.
He simply has really persuasive
and interesting and thoughtful
things to say, and
the kindest ethos,
both at the institutional
and personal level,
somebody that I find
myself going to for counsel
and many, many others as well.
And I have yet to
receive a bill.
So that's how I know he's
really not a practicing lawyer.
So John, we're so
pleased to see you.
Note that in some
quirk of things,
there are exactly three copies
of this book available for sale
around the corner.
JOHN PALFREY: That's either a
good sign or a really bad sign.
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN: Yes.
But they will also, because
they only have three copies,
put you on the list to order one
on layaway at a 30% discount.
So that's a good
deal of the evening.
John, you are 100% here.
Thank you so much for
spending time with us tonight.
We're so excited
what you have to say.
JOHN PALFREY: Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
And thank you all for coming.
This is very touching to
see such a great crowd.
I feel like I'm
coming home in a way,
and to see so many
people that I've
worked with, both at the Berkman
Center and the Harvard Law
School Library and the
Harvard libraries broadly.
I'm truly, truly
grateful to see you here.
This book that I have
written is a love letter
to libraries and to
those who work in them,
the librarians in particular.
It is also, I hope,
an argument for why
libraries are so
crucial, especially
in the age of Google.
And all of that I learned from
those people in this room,
and I'm really grateful for
all of your help in doing it.
I'm going to try to talk for
no more than 20 or 25 minutes,
and then hopefully
get into conversation.
I would love to hear much
of what is on your minds
and be challenged,
as Jonathan said,
with questions I haven't
yet heard on this book tour.
This may the only
place on my book tour
where somebody will know
what this actually is.
Is there anybody who
recognizes this picture?
AUDIENCE: Your office?
JOHN PALFREY: No.
It comes from--
yes, [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Oliver
Wendell Holmes' library?
JOHN PALFREY: Yes,
that's so great.
This is the first
time someone has
known the answer
to that question,
and I ask it everywhere.
This is the personal library of
Oliver Wendell Holmes Jr., who
of course was a professor here.
But this was actually his
home in Washington, DC.
And I love this picture for
a whole bunch of reasons.
It reminds me of the Harvard Law
School Library and the awesome
librarians and archivists
who work in it,
and the fact that they digitized
this amazing collection
of Oliver Wendell Holmes'.
But it also to me is a
great challenge to all of us
when we think about
libraries and the libraries
of the future.
And the reason I see it as a
challenge is this room to me
is really, really
appealing-- the idea
that you could have
a space in your home
that is surrounded by books in
this way and sit in that chair
and think of all
the great opinions
that Holmes thought up.
Now, we know he
had a few clangers
and so forth, so he
thought up some bad ones.
And maybe he didn't do it here.
But just the idea that he was
inspired by sitting there.
And for many of us, we
work with young people.
I now live with and work
with about 1,100 teenagers,
and I think a ton about
what inspires them.
What kind of space
would inspire them?
What kind of a
library space would?
And for most of our
teenagers, my guess
is that this might be a
cool and inspiring space,
but for almost none of
them would they sit up,
swirl around that chair,
and then pull one of those
off the shelf.
For those of us who've worked in
the Harvard Law School Library,
I was always struck by the
fact that we were almost always
full as a library.
Cheek by jowl those
kids were there.
Very often they
had those approved
Harvard Law School Library mugs.
And they had a casebook, right?
And they were highlighting
away on the casebook,
but they weren't doing a
ton of pulling statutes
or other things off
the shelves-- almost
never, at least in the big
reading room, literally never.
And maybe if they had a
great reference librarian
they might have found something.
But by and large, they were
there for other reasons.
Right?
They are there probably
right now studying away
for other reasons.
And I think our challenge,
in a way, in a digital era
is to come up with
something that
is as powerful and
appealing a space for kids
as a learning space and as
an environment in libraries.
And I think that's the
challenge back on all of us who
are trying to design and
to create these spaces
in an exciting way.
And I think we do this against
a backdrop where libraries
are to some extent in peril.
Now, I stand in a room,
I realize, at Harvard,
the place where unbelievable
support for libraries exists.
But even within Harvard,
we know that there
are different schools
that support libraries
at different levels.
Our dean is here.
Meet Dean Minow.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for being a lover of
libraries, not just evidenced
by the fact that you're here
but because of all you do
to make libraries great here.
But even within the
context of Harvard,
we went through
several year period
of quite a bit of transition.
And I was a part of that too.
And we know that there are
times when libraries are
under a great deal of pressure.
That is true in
academic settings,
and obviously this is a
difficult context for many.
But it's particularly true,
I think, in public libraries.
And as I've traveled around
in school libraries--
the 100,000 or so school
libraries around the country--
very often people
have a funny view
that libraries aren't maybe
as useful as they once
were, which I think
is exactly wrong,
which is why I wrote this book.
This is a quote from
an Amazon review
by somebody I do not know.
His name is David Weinberg.
It is not David
Weinberger our friend.
But this was a not
particularly flattering review
on Amazon of my book, and
it was disagreeing basically
with the premise of
the importance of it.
But I thought it was a
particularly good view that
sums up what some
people think, and it
is a prevailing view out there.
I realized often also when
I was reading the book
that one of the most common
conversations that I had
after becoming the Director of
the Harvard Law School Library
was one at a backyard
barbecue or a cocktail
party, and someone would
come up to me and say,
so what are you up to?
And I would say,
I'm just becoming
the director of this library.
And then two seconds later
the person would interrupt me
and say, oh, wait
a minute, libraries
aren't as useful anymore.
You're the digital guy.
You're getting rid of them.
You're getting rid
of all the books.
And then they'd
have walked away.
In this sense, I never had the
chance to kind of grab them
and say, no, no, no, libraries
are more important than ever
and here's what we have to do.
And so that's why I
wrote the book in a way,
was to answer that question
for all those people who
walked away from me at parties.
They're not probably going
to be reading the book.
I get the irony of that.
But I still felt I had
to win the argument.
But I say it in a
serious tone, which
is we recognize that in
many communities, when
there is a choice between
money for police and fire
and education and other
important things--
and this is true in my
hometown now of Andover,
too-- the library doesn't
get as much support.
The support is eroding for
libraries in these communities,
and I think we need to
reverse that polarity.
We do this also, though, I
think, in the context, at least
in the United States,
of an amazing culture
of support for libraries
and a history of support
for libraries.
This image comes from our
hometown of Boston right
across the river.
Every time I see
this I get chills
down my spine, the
idea of free to all;
the idea that the big municipal
public libraries started right
here about 150 years ago,
and with an incredibly
simple democratic premise--
the basic idea that information
should be free, knowledge should
be free, to anyone, regardless
of their ability to pay.
And this was something that
is in the cradle of the Athens
that we created here in
Boston, the middle of our city
in Copley Square.
And so we have a
history of making
this kind of amazing
support for our communities,
for our democracies.
And part of what I worry
about in this moment of peril
for libraries is that we
will lose sight of that,
and that oddly, we
actually might backtrack.
We might actually have less
access in our democracy
to information in the digital
age than in an analog age.
And that would be terrible.
That would be, I
think, perverse.
I think that's true for
a variety of reasons.
And a simplistic
version of that argument
is to say, increasingly, as
knowledge moves to the cloud,
one could imagine it being
vastly more available,
that anybody with
one of these devices
could get access to
whatever they wanted.
But there are a couple
reasons why that's
not so simple or so true.
One is if you look at the
owners of the cloud in essence,
they're almost
all private firms.
They're almost all parties that
are private companies and doing
it for profit-- which
is not a bad thing,
and this is not an
anti-corporate screed so much
as to say public
spaces in cyberspace
have been things that
we've had to win.
It's what Jonathan Zittrain and
Yochai Benkler and the Berkman
Center have had to create and
really care for and establish.
As we hurtle to a
cloud-based environment,
by and large we turn to private
players like Amazon and others
to store our stuff.
So in a very simple
mode, if we increasingly
create our materials and
put them in private hands
as opposed to, say, in the
public hands-- or roughly
speaking, public-spirited
hands of libraries
and the research universities
that have libraries--
I think that is a
dangerous thing.
There are many other ways
in which it's tricky,
and we can come back to that.
But I think it is
something worth worrying
about a little bit.
There's a way to make
this a bit more precise,
which is for those who've
worked in libraries,
you know that it's not
always possible for libraries
to do exactly in the
digital age what they've
done in the physical age.
One of the ways in which this is
true is the lending of ebooks.
So by and large,
publishers have made
it tricky to lend
ebooks on the same terms
that you could lend
a physical book.
This is where it
is relevant that we
are at a school, of course,
because in fact they're treated
in two really different ways.
The background law for
lending stuff like this
is actually really, really good.
The background copyright, in
a simple sense, is positive.
Which is, libraries
for hundreds of years
have been able to buy
something like this
and then do more
or less whatever
they wanted with it, right?
You could bring it to
a secondhand book shop
and sell it, or you could
lend it as many times
as you wanted or
you could tear it up
or you could digitize it
and do lots of things.
But it turns out that if
you get that same book
and you put it on
one of these devices
and a library is wishing to get
it on terms that it can license
to someone else, all of a
sudden it is governed not
by the background copyright
law so much as it is governed
by the contract law that
the company sets up,
the publisher sets
up with the library.
And for all those who've
worked in libraries,
you know that you can't always
get e-books on as good terms
as you can get physical books.
And some of the outcomes
are perverse and bizarre,
like you can't read it aloud.
Those are some of the
worst of the terms.
Some of the other terms
have been the 26-lend rule.
Does anybody remember
that great offering
from a publisher,
the notion that you
could get one of these for
whatever the full price was
and Jonathan and I could lend
it back and forth 26 times,
and then of course
it would go away
because it would have worn out.
Right?
That premise didn't
work out all that well.
The basic idea, though,
is that it has not
been possible for libraries
to get digital materials on as
good a deal, or
in fact, as often,
as they could get
it in physical form.
And this, I think, is
a dangerous premise.
It's also the case
that when it is
a contract between the
company and the library,
there's also something
tricky behind it with respect
to the ability to store it
over a long period of time too.
So if the point
is we're paying it
as though we were leasing for
it, when we stop paying for it,
it could go away.
So in fact, libraries
might in fact not
have collections if we were
only turning from owners
of the information
and the knowledge
into those who are
leasing it, or renters.
And many people
have worked on this
from many different angles.
Here, I would say, in the cradle
of the open access movement.
That is one great answer
to it, where at the FAS
level and Bob Darnton and
others led the effort there,
and at Harvard Law
School, where we've
committed to putting our
materials in the commons
in an open access way.
That's not such a big deal.
But for the vast majority of
what is created and published,
we actually have potentially
a less good arrangement
going forward if we don't
change the deal that is being
offered for digital materials.
Just out of curiosity, if
you were reading something,
how many people still prefer
this, a hard-copy kind of book?
Vast majority.
How many people prefer an ebook?
Relatively few.
And how many people are
more or less agnostic,
you kind of do both?
Interesting.
I think that may be the
growing group actually,
is those who want to
read this at night
but carry this on a plane.
I think that's kind
of the growth of it.
Oh, Stuart Schieber, also
the open access champion.
I'm sorry, I didn't you
see you there before.
Congratulations and thank you.
But the basic
point being that we
need to ensure that
in a digital age
there is just as much access
from a democratic perspective
as there's been, if not more so.
So this picture shows
a moment in time
when we were actually
building that Boston Public
Library, when we were putting
up this amazing edifice
in the middle of Copley Square.
It was a few decades
after the library started.
It was 1890.
And the reason I
love this picture is
because I think that's,
roughly speaking, the moment
we find ourselves in now.
We have a moment where we
are building for the future
the next set of libraries.
And it is a set
of libraries that
will exist both in digital
form and in physical form.
And I think we actually ought
to be thinking about this
in architectural form.
So does anybody
recognize this one?
A lot of people work
in this building.
This is a side elevation
of Langdell Hall.
And it is to my mind the
moment that we're in right now,
which is where we are
convening together,
I think-- or ought to be
convening-- those people who
think about information
architecture and the importance
of the digital era
and how we actually
frame and make
accessible information
with the analog era.
I think that future will
be a hybrid of libraries
that are very much physical
spaces, but also which
connect to the cyberspace
that we are creating.
And I think in order to do
that well, what we need to do
is actually convene all
of these people together
and actually work in a way
that is much more collaborative
than we've done in the past.
One of the ways in which
we've been doing that--
and many people in this
room are to thank for that;
Bob Darnton called together a
group of 40 people at Radcliffe
Institute a few years ago
to convene an effort really
to say, can we in fact
come up with the design
for a combined public
and private effort
to create a combined
hybrid digital
and physical infrastructure?
That has become the idea
behind the Digital Public
Library of America.
40 people in that room actually
agreed to this sentence,
"To create an open
distributed network
of comprehensive
online resources."
And that's sort of a
crazy ambitious thing
that nobody thought in fact
could work, but somehow it has.
And Rebecca Haycock
and many people
here have made it come together.
I think it's one
example of what we
can do to solve this problem.
OK, so pause there
for a second and say,
what are the elements of
a library in a digital age
that the Digital Public Library
of America and other things
might be able to bring about?
I think fundamentally,
libraries remain about people.
So I think that the
crucial aspect of libraries
is keeping the humanity
in the transaction
between people and information,
people and knowledge.
I think one of the challenges
that people often throw out
about libraries is we don't need
them so much, because people
can help themselves so easily
through these kinds of devices.
One example of
this that struck me
as I was writing a book about
the importance of librarians
happened in a small-town
library in Andover, Mass.
I was editing one chapter
and it was about 3:00
in the afternoon.
A whole pile of kids came
in after school, which
is a fun thing that happens.
Libraries fill up with
students who are spilling out
of schools when they close.
And the kids all went into the
teen section, and some of them
were doing their homework and
others were gaming and doing
other things.
And one of them was trying
to do a science thing.
And the kid turned to
his iPhone he said,
Siri, what does
terminal velocity mean?
This was in the
middle of a library.
And Siri, it turned
out, did not know
what terminal velocity meant.
[LAUGHTER]
But like three feet away
was an amazing librarian.
And I was sure that that woman
could have either told him
exactly what terminal velocity
meant or at least shown him--
probably better--
the way to find out
about terminal velocity.
You see these examples
over and over again,
but I think it is
important to note.
And this is one of the
aspects of this book that
is a little challenging.
There is a tough-love
story here,
which is when we
study young people
and how they look
for information,
librarians are pretty
low on that list.
The project information
literacy studies
are probably the
clearest in that zone,
that kids often do look
to Google and Wikipedia.
They often look
to their teachers
in that particular class.
But we have to do a
better job, I think,
as librarians and people who
work in libraries, to ensure
that kids actually do go
and use these resources
and know to do that,
and we actually
have to prompt them to do it
and to teach them to do it.
But I start with the
humanity as a key element
of libraries in a digital age.
Second, I think
libraries have to shift
from being standalone silos--
which I think there have been
lots of reasons for them
to be-- to being platforms
and to being connected entities.
So this, I think,
invokes a lot of the work
that Yochai has done in
the wealth of networks
and otherwise.
If you think about the
history of libraries,
go back thousands of
years to the library
at the Palace of
Ebla, for instance,
in modern day Syria, or
the Library of Alexandria--
the idea behind the
library in a way
was you brought
all that material.
Whatever you could
get, you brought it
to a particular place.
And now you may think
about it as bringing
to a particular school,
a particular zip code,
all of those materials.
And that was understandable
as a previous iteration
of libraries.
I still think to some extent
we do that, and too often
I sometimes hear of schools
bragging about how many volumes
they have or how much they
spend on their libraries
in order to attract
kids or people.
I think that misses the point.
I think it misses the point
that by working much more
together and actually
by seeing libraries
as a connected
series of platforms,
as part of the network, they
can accomplish much more.
This particular
design of a platform
is the DPLA's rough
structure, the Digital Public
Library of America.
And the key to it,
in a way, is the fact
that it is just a whole
pile of open source
code with a whole pile of
open metadata and as much open
access material as
you possibly can have,
and a bunch of
different parties.
In this case, service
hubs are states
by and large, Content hubs are
things like Harvard University.
Thank you, [? Sara ?]
Thomas and others
for contributing material in.
And the ability to export on
a bulk basis for anybody who
wishes to do it.
And as you see from the
top, the notion that nobody
has yet figured
out the right way
to present library
material in a digital age.
And the point is
that we can have
lots of potential frontends.
We can have lots of different
applications and ways
to share our materials,
especially if we think of them
as platforms, pool the
materials together,
and make it possible through
an open API, an ability
to create any front-end
that you would like.
So today there is one way
to get it, which is dp.la.
You could go on your mobile
device or your computer,
and you can find a
search engine and a way
into all of these materials.
But likewise, if you
go back a screen,
that's just this
particular front-end.
I think the ultimate
success of the project
is that any library could
create on this open API
the ability to find a better
way to do this presentation,
to find a way to
present this material.
And any library could create an
application or a front-end that
would in fact make it
so that nobody even
knew that the DPLA was there.
The DPLA could be,
ultimately, entirely plumbing,
and the success be in the way
in which different communities
have presented this material.
That's a very different way
of thinking about libraries
as institutions, but it's
about taking advantage
of what the miracles
of the web have
made possible and that magic.
And that, I think, requires
us to be a little bit less
egocentric as
institutions and much more
seeing it as a way to share.
As of right now, just a small
plug for where the DPLA is.
We have filled up about a third
of the map in terms of places
contributing materials
into this Digital Public
Library of America.
The red states-- I
suppose that's maybe
not the colors we should have
used for this in this room--
are the ones that do have up
and running-- actually it's
perfect, Harvard colors, in
that way-- have service hubs.
So if you look at
Massachusetts, we
have the Digital Commonwealth.
And if you think about what
the Digital Commonwealth is,
it's a fabulous example for
what the rest of the country
could do.
So at the Boston
Public Library there
are people like [? I, ?]
Tom Blake and a team,
and what they do is they go out
to all the 351 cities and towns
in the Commonwealth
of Massachusetts
and help them digitize materials
and add metadata to it,
and then share it up
through a statewide portal.
What the DPLA does is it
creates a way to share
that on a national basis.
So if you imagine,
if every state
had a Digital
Commonwealth equivalent,
we would in fact be
building for the country
an amazing series of
on-ramps into something
that everybody could access.
We're about a third
of the way there.
Dan Cohen, who's the
current executive director,
and others are doing a fabulous
job of filling out this map.
If you happen to come from any
of these states that do not yet
have a DPLA hub and
you'd like to be one,
let us know because we can
get you signed right up.
The other thing that's
important to look at
are these yellow ones,
the content hubs.
Those are the big
institutions like Harvard
and others-- bless you-- who
are in the process of digitizing
tons of material and making them
available in this particular
way to the rest of the country.
And my hunch is, if we could
have every institution doing
what the National Archive
is doing and doing
what Smithsonian is doing and
New York Public and Harvard
and so forth, we would
be creating potentially
the most amazing library that
has ever existed in the world.
And that, I think, is a
very exciting premise.
Much of it does come
from the work of people
who are literally in this room.
This is the Oliver
Wendell Holmes suite,
which is all of those
materials, including
that first image that I showed.
And if you think about
these collections that
once were called hidden
collections at Harvard--
they were sort of hidden away in
different places-- I think even
if we just put them
on the web and we
have people come
find them, they're
still a little bit hidden.
And I think part of
the key to the step
that we're taking right
now, and particularly
as we take amazing collections
like the Oliver Wendell Holmes
collection and other ones that
are extremely well-curated
and shared, we can
make them unhidden
in this same network model
by putting it in the DPLA.
Now, of course, we should
caveat the problem of copyright.
We'll come back to that later.
But subject to any licenses that
we have that we can share it,
I think putting things
in this shared repository
makes them much more valuable.
Second, I think that by
doing it in this way,
in an open way with an open
API as a chance for people
to be able to do anything they
wish with the information,
we'll be able to unleash
a whole lot of innovation.
So this is an old schematic, but
one that came from the Harvard
Library Innovation Lab.
I'm going to give a
couple examples from that.
You may think about libraries
and worry about some
of the things we
would lose if we
were to go in a digital
direction, which
we continue to.
I think one of those fears
has been serendipity,
the idea that if you do not
have physical libraries,
you don't actually have a shelf.
You don't have a place where
you can go and get a call number
and walk in and find
a book you want,
and then see all those
other amazing books that
are to the right and
the left of them.
And you probably all
have that experience
of coming out with 10
books when you thought
you were coming out with one.
And I think that's
one of those things
that we don't want
to lose when we
go from physical libraries
to whatever future
we're going toward.
My hunch is that
even if we contract
those stacks a little bit--
and we shouldn't contract them
anymore than we
already have, just
to be clear-- we actually can
do some things that introduce
new forms of serendipity.
We actually might be
able, in a hybrid world,
to do better than we have
done in just the analog.
And why is that?
One reason, to take
the Harvard example--
what is the current count
of Harvard libraries?
Is it still in the 70s?
73?
AUDIENCE: 73.
JOHN PALFREY: 73 distinct
libraries within a system.
The fact of the matter
is, when you also
add in the depository
25 miles away,
there's actually no
stack at Harvard.
There's no place
where you could walk
in and see all the books, all
the collection, in the system.
So if you could imagine
a world in which you
have the stacks that are
fabulous ones in Widener
and here and Langdell and so
forth as one place to walk in,
but you also could combine all
the materials from all those 73
libraries, plus all the
materials in the Harvard
depository in a virtual sense,
and create a virtual stack,
you could have new
forms of serendipity.
You could actually
find connections
that were not previously
possible or findable.
This was an example.
Stack View was a
rendering, a way
to put all of the
Harvard collection
together, as you may know.
This was based on
2009 circulation data,
so circulation data
from a long time ago.
And the basic idea
was very simple.
The idea was you
could then search
on different forms of
metadata that people have
added into their collections.
So in this particular
case, someone
is searching for
Gravity's Rainbow,
and they can see how many
times that particular book has
circulated in a
certain period of time.
But you also might see that
another book has circulated
much more frequently.
You could also
search, of course,
if you're a graduate student,
how many of your professors
have checked out this
version or another.
You could imagine if
it were The Illiad
and we had 40
examples of that, you
might want to search on
which of those translations
or which of those forwards
was most important.
You could imagine ways in which
all of that great metadata that
librarians have could become
more valuable if it were
a combination of the digital
with the physical in somebody's
hands.
And I think that is the
possibility that lies ahead
of us, and why this
research and development
effort, particularly on top of
open systems, is so important.
I would add one other example
that I think is crucial.
Also in the Harvard Library
innovation lab is perma.cc.
For those who haven't followed
this particular effort,
I think it's an
amazing example of why
libraries have a crucial
role to play going forward.
I've talked mostly
about the importance
in a democratic society
of access to information,
and I think that is really
the primary one for libraries.
But I think preservation of
information and preservation
of where the
information is found
is equally important in
many respects for libraries.
One thing I fear is that if
we don't actually think ahead
to the kinds of
systems that we ought
to have for the
long-term, we're going
to make an enormous mistake.
I think perma.cc is
one example of how
we can create permanent
forms of digital archiving,
and where librarians
actually can lead in a way
that we have not
one as much before.
This is a project that
is currently ongoing.
I know Jonathan and his
team-- we could talk about it
afterwards, so I won't explain
it entirely, and leave you
the chance to do it.
But I think it's an example of
the amazing innovation that's
happening in libraries, and
the importance of libraries
playing this role.
One of the challenges that we've
put out to libraries in general
is if you think about
in the information
era in the last
several years, I don't
think most of the
big innovations
have actually come
out of libraries.
So if you think
about search, that
has come out of, obviously,
big companies like Google.
If you think about
recommendations,
by and large that has
come out of big companies
like Amazon and Netflix, maybe.
If you think about
encyclopedias,
that came out of a
commodity trader's head,
and a bunch of people are
collaborating in Wikipedia.
Lots of other examples of it.
But I actually think
libraries have not
been on the forefront of
the very big innovations,
and I still think that lies
ahead as a possibility.
And with a series of open
systems and collaboration,
I think that's entirely,
entirely possible.
I'm about to bring it
in for a landing, so
here's the windup to that.
I think ultimately, the thing
that libraries need most to do
and where I think
most of the excitement
is actually solving a series of
problems that face communities.
And as I go around the country
talking about this book
or in the context of
DPLA, it's so clear
that from many,
many perspectives,
libraries have a crucial
role to play in communities.
And that could be very simply,
providing access to kids
after school when they don't
have another place to access
information because
they actually don't have
a broadband connection at home.
You hear many kids getting
assigned kinds of homework
that they actually can't
complete without being
able to go to a library.
And I heard from kids who at
6:00 when the library closed
then had to go to
McDonald's or Starbucks,
because that's where
the free Wi-Fi was.
I think there's an enormously
powerful role in bridging
this participation gap
and the digital divide
from the library perspective.
I think that's true
for job seekers.
It's true for people who are
new immigrants to the country.
I think it's true for
elderly people who come
to libraries as a social place.
These are hugely important roles
that libraries continue to play
outside of the scholarly realm.
And I won't go through
all those examples,
because everybody knows
them so well here.
I think in the end we do need
libraries as physical spaces.
Does anybody recognize
this library?
AUDIENCE: The John
Adams Library?
JOHN PALFREY: Yes, The John
Adams Library in Quincy, Mass.
They're just such
amazing spaces that
have been created in libraries.
So my argument in
no way is to say
that we shouldn't
have physical spaces,
glorious physical spaces,
in our communities.
I think libraries
play an essential role
in creating third spaces
that are open and public.
I just think that
people may come to them
for different reasons, and
we may need to support them
for very different reasons.
One thing you see about
the Adams library--
you can imagine at
this table that these
were big reference tomes.
I don't think people
are necessarily
going to come to a library
for reference tomes.
They're going to come
for other reasons.
And I think part of our job is
to figure out what those are.
I think we will continue
to have physical books.
My argument is not in any
way that we won't actually
have physical and beautiful
objects that present material.
I'm not positive that the market
will be exactly as it is today.
My sense is we will have very
beautiful physical objects
and things that present in large
sizes and in beautiful formats,
and we will have mostly
digital materials otherwise.
I think things will be
mostly born digital.
I suspect that e-books will
press on that paperback
market or the market of
less beautiful objects,
but I think we still
do have a material
culture that people like.
And even kids seem to continue
like those physical objects,
so I don't think
they're going away.
But we do have to
figure out a way--
how do we support libraries
when patrons hold up
their hands just the way
you did in this room, many
saying I prefer the paper, some
saying you prefer the digital.
And with a trend toward
increasingly digital, one
of the things that
we have put libraries
in such a tough
position with is saying,
with the same amount
of money or less money,
you have to do both the digital
stuff and the physical stuff.
That is an untenable position.
We've got to figure
out a way, whether it's
through collaboration
or continuing
to support through funding
or it's capital investment,
to allow libraries
to be able to thrive
in what is going to be
both physical and digital
as a world.
I think we should do it in a
global context, to be sure.
And this was one of the parts
of Bob's genius and others
as we started out with
the Digital Public
Library of America.
Yes, of course, it's been
seen as a national effort,
but it's been done in an
international context.
The United States is actually
not the first country
to come up with a digital
strategy for their nation.
The Europeans actually are
much further ahead, at least
time-wise, in the form of
Europeana, as an example.
And very much the first
thing that DPLA did
was to find a way to
work with the Europeans.
And the notion was
not to say, we're
just going to create one
worldwide library or one
worldwide digital
library of Alexandria,
but to say we can actually have
maybe 200 different countries
having theirs, but figure out
how to make them interoperable.
How do you ensure
that from the user
perspective people actually
can access these materials?
So one of the first
things DPLA did
was to create an
exhibit on immigration
that showed people
going from the old world
to the new and the
new world to the old,
to ensure that as we built
this system it would actually
work on a global level.
We have the diversity
and the difference
and the innovation that happens
in all these different country
levels, but we actually
connect it in a global vision.
And in some ways
most importantly,
I put up here a map of Utopia.
You can see it here.
My view is we should
dream really, really big.
This is the moment
when we are designing
what public libraries and
scholarly libraries and school
libraries can and should
be for the future.
And I am not so pollyannish
to say that we are absolutely
going to become a utopia.
That's not the point.
But the point is we should
have something that we actually
are building toward in mind.
It should be a shared
vision that we're
really excited about.
And I feel like that's
entirely, entirely possible,
to put that vision ahead of us
and to build as much toward it
as we can, and to
say that we are not
going to accept a digital
world or a digital hybrid
with the physical world that's
actually less good than what
we've had in the past
in terms of access,
in terms of preservation,
in terms of commitment
to democratic ideals.
And I think that it's an
extremely exciting moment
to come together.
So I hope very
much that you will
share your questions with me.
But most importantly,
thank you for being
engaged in a discussion about
the future of libraries.
And I look forward to
working with all of you
to make it very bright.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you indeed for this
sparkling call to action.
We should take
questions, comments.
So hands are going up.
Microphones are
with Dan, at least.
So Dan, get it going.
And feel free to
tell us who you are.
JOHN PALFREY: And
argument's most welcome.
Hard questions go to Jonathan.
AUDIENCE: Good evening.
My name is
[? Yungtan Kamensky. ?]
I'm an incoming student
at Simmons GSLIS,
and I was intrigued by
the discussion of trying
to replicate serendipity
in the digital world,
particularly the slide
with Gravity's Rainbow,
looking at metadata while trying
to replicate the experience
of viewing items on a stack.
Has anyone looked at
doing the opposite?
And what I mean is
taking the digital
and putting it in the
physical stacks, probably
through augmented reality
technologies-- maybe
something as simple as QR codes.
People all have fancy little
computers in their hands.
It seems to me there'd
be some way to do that.
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN:
Oculus Library.
You'd be staggering around.
You could do it right here
and just pull stuff off.
Is that the idea?
AUDIENCE: Something a little
bit less cumbersome, hopefully.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN PALFREY: Sounds
like a fabulous project,
and a great one for you to do
during your master's degree,
for sure, or PhD--
whatever comes next.
In a serious way,
I think the group
that I've heard most talking
about this kind of thing
around here-- is
Jeffrey Schnapp here,
or others who worked with
the Library Test Kitchen?
This is very much
the kind of thing
that group was working on.
I would restate a little bit
what I was trying to say,
which was not
entirely to replace
to take the physical
experience and put it online
but really to rethink what the
combination of those two things
would be.
And I think that's
exactly your point, which
is some of the things
that might actually work
would be looking
at what are some
of the pathways that
people use today
online that actually could
supplement or augment
the physical?
And I think that's where
excitement would lie,
would be that interface
between those two
and trying to make an
experience that could be better
than what we've had to date.
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN: Can
we navigate the mic up
to the next place?
Here's one from Armand, too.
We can alternate
back and forth, so.
BOB DARNTON: John,
I would like to ask
a self-interested
question, because I've
just written
something about that
is an attempt at an answer.
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN: And you
should, just for the record,
identify yourself, Bob.
BOB DARNTON: I'm Bob Darnton,
University Librarian.
What do you think should be the
top priorities for the Library
of Congress, and what
should the new librarian,
who will assume his or her
position on January 1, do?
JOHN PALFREY: Thats'
a wonderful question.
Well, Professor Darnton, I
think the first thing that
should happen is that the
President should invite
you to take up that
post in a few months
now that you're available,
which I think would be fun.
I think the next
person should do
a couple things that I think
the Library of Congress
has not done.
One is, in a fundamental
way, to see itself
as a national library.
And I think the Library of
Congress in some respects
has dodged that for a long
time, by saying in part
it's a research
arm of the Congress
and in part it's our national
library, but not quite.
I think you have
to grab it and say,
this is the national library,
and we are not the whole thing
but we are connected
to the rest of it,
and should actually
play nice with the rest.
And to say that there in fact
is a really positive role
that the Library of Congress
can play in an interconnected
and networked world.
I think that would be one.
I think two would
be then-- so that's
sort of a conceptual shift,
but an important one.
And two would be to take
on mass digitization
in a meaningful way.
So I think that
people have often
pointed to the World
Digital Library
and the 11,000 or so objects
that have been digitized it it.
That's too small a number,
I think, for internet scale.
And I think for an entity
like the Library of Congress
to take up this job
of mass digitilization
and to work with the
National Archives, which
has been hard at work at it,
the Smithsonian, the GPO, lots
of other parties
in the government,
and actually lead that
effort-- I think that could
be enormously powerful.
A third thing would
be join the DPLA.
So one of the
absurdities, I think,
of the process we've
had for five years
is that we have the
National Archives,
we have the Smithsonian,
we have the GPO,
we have lots of other federal
agencies participating.
And yet, the Library
of Congress has
resisted our invitations for
all that time, which seems to me
bizarre.
Anyway, I could
go down the list.
But I think the opportunities
for leadership--
particularly in
the digital realm,
but in that combination
of the digital
and the physical--
could be enormous.
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN:
Wherever the other mic is.
JOHN PALFREY: Ah, Dean Minow.
MARTHA MINOW: Dean Minow.
John, it's just so
fabulous, the book.
Everyone should buy it.
Don't take the 30% discount.
Just give him all the money.
JOHN PALFREY: You see
why we love our dean?
[LAUGHTER]
MARTHA MINOW: Well,
it's such a great book
because you open up
what the possibilities
that the digital world
offers to open up libraries,
while identifying what the
traditional libraries have that
are at risk.
My question to you
is really threefold.
One, what business models
do you see going forward
that can make the vision real?
Secondly, what
legal changes would
be necessary and feasible
to make the changes real?
And the third is, aren't there
possibilities that we never
saw before, like
makerspaces, where
the interactivity between
the digital and the physical
may open up something
we never had before?
JOHN PALFREY: Those are
three awesome questions.
So the first one, which
is the hardest one,
is the business model question.
My view is that by and
large, libraries shouldn't
have to have a business model.
So by and large,
there is a public--
[APPLAUSE]
Look at that.
That's so good.
Basically, I think
libraries are a public good.
And I think that
the business should
be that through our
taxpayer dollars
we should support
public libraries.
And the United States
really is the leader.
And actually, Boston
really has been
the leader of that
since the BPL opened,
then lots of small-town
libraries-- all those great HH
Richardson buildings
that look like Sever Hall
and look like parts
of the law school,
those are the early formation
of the public library
system in the country.
And then of course there's
the Carnegie libraries
that spread out
1,600 communities
wide in the early 20th century.
So I think they should
be publicly financed,
by and large.
I do think that philanthropy
has a huge role to play,
and one of the arguments
that I make in the book
is to say that, at moments
of key transition--
as Mr. Carnegie
did; and there are
lots of reasons to
criticize Carnegie,
but one thing he did was
he put a lot of capital
into libraries that spread
them from big cities
into lots of small towns
at a crucial moment.
So I actually
think it'd be great
if the Carnegie Corporation
or the MacArthur
Foundation or others would
in fact stand up and say,
this is a moment to do a
big investment of that sort.
After that, I think one of
the questions is to say,
should libraries
be in the business
of selling stuff
or having a revenue
model that looks otherwise?
I think that libraries,
archives, museums,
are all asking these
kinds of questions.
There are, of course, things
that we can license and make
some money on.
This library here, of course,
has made some amount of money
on royalties by virtue of
taking materials we had
and digitizing those, allowing
people then to sell them back
to us or other libraries.
I think there's
something in that.
But I would much rather
see a business model that
was focused on
collaboration, and one
that was focused on open
access and other things
that I actually think we
have the seeds of here,
rather than see it
as something where
we actually have to have a
corporate-style business model.
But others may disagree.
Second of the three questions,
about legal changes--
I think just to
state it really fast,
Orphan Works legislation
should change.
So to Bob's question,
one of the great things
about the Library of Congress
is that position overseas,
the Register of Copyrights.
So the Library of
Congress could stand up
and say, look,
really simply, nobody
is hurt by having Orphan Works
legislation-- tens of millions
of works that could be
made available that are not
being made available.
And if somebody finds that
they're the copyright holder,
they then will be able to
put it back into copyright
if they wish to, or not.
And in fact, I just can't see
how Orphan Works legislation
doesn't really help everyone.
Section 108 reform--
there are special rules
that relate to libraries.
There are special rules that
allow libraries to do things,
for instance, for those who
have different abilities-- so
for the blind and otherwise.
There are specific rules that
are way out of date and ought
to be reformed.
So we've gone a certain
distance on Section 108 reform.
We could go further
and so forth.
So there are a series
of things, I think,
in that area that are crucial.
And the other piece
of legal reform
that needs to be tied to
that is privacy reform.
I think libraries have
done such a great job
of being the places where
we protect reader privacy.
We need to ensure that
the law allows libraries
to do that on an ongoing basis.
And last, makerspaces--
yes, for sure.
One of the things you
pushed me to do when I first
took this job was to focus
on co-production, the idea
that libraries are spaces
in which we are producing
new knowledge of various sorts.
Makerspaces are one example.
The new media labs popping up
around the country are another.
I think they're great
examples of bringing people
into libraries to
create new knowledge.
I feel like that's the
excitement of having
an open application
programming interface layer,
and so forth, which is
in-person and from afar
we can create new things
that have never existed.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Hi, John.
Pat McCormick, former
student, Kennedy School grad.
I can't wait to read the book.
So excuse me if
this is in the book.
JOHN PALFREY: No
problem. [INAUDIBLE]
one way or the other.
AUDIENCE: OK.
I'm very interested in the API
and the platform and all that,
but my question is more mundane.
In the city where
I live, Somerville,
we're struggling to keep library
branches open, to restore them,
to create new spaces
that aren't traditional.
And it seems like
this concept would
allow us to open a library with
fewer books-- assuming we have
the platform as well;
that's not to say
we don't need the books--
in different spaces
to restore historic
buildings and reuse them
in different ways.
And I was just
wondering the extent
to which you've
thought about this
as a way of creating more
flexibility, lower cost
barriers for physical
libraries in our cities.
JOHN PALFREY: That's
a great question.
And I understand Somerville
has a fabulous new librarian.
You've got-- it's
an exciting moment
for Somerville in particular.
So my preferred answer was
that we fund libraries fully,
and that they have a fabulous
physical infrastructure
and branches that are open.
Actually, one of the things
that Boston Public Library did
was introduce the branch
system, as well-- so
have lots of
community-based libraries,
and support them well.
I think the reality is that
we don't in communities often
make that full investment.
And I think that's where we
have to say, so what can we do?
How do we embrace this future
while also doing as much
of the fabulous existing
stuff as we can?
I think the only answer
there is to collaborate,
is to say that we
don't need to bring
the same collection to every
one of these physical spaces.
Librarians, of course, have done
this very well for a long time
with interlibrary loan
and with a variety
of other forms of
sharing, but I think
those can be amped up and
done more extensively.
And of course, as
I've argued, I think
from a digital
perspective, every library
should not be creating
its own iPad app.
Not every library
should be creating
its own various digital systems.
That is something
that we can, if we
take a page enough out of
the open source movement,
do in a collaborative way.
And I think that would
allow for communities
to make choices as to how they
spend what are scarcer dollars.
So would I rather see
fewer books in libraries?
Of course not.
But I think where we have
to make that choice--
do as much collaboration
as possible
to allow as much
choice as possible.
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN: Over here.
Did the mic find a new home?
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name
is Ron [? Newman. ?]
I've been using libraries
for about 54 years.
I wanted to come back to that
slide and what it represents.
It's very seductive.
On the other hand, it also shows
a limitation of physical stacks
as they are now, which is
that a book, as it comes
into the library, gets one
Dewey decimal or Library
of Congress number and
forever that's the one
place where it is.
In a digital system
you can do better
than that, because
that book can sit
on many different shelf lists.
Is there opportunity
for some sort of wiki
kind of cataloging system
to emerge from this so
that many people can
collectively catalog material
better than one person can?
JOHN PALFREY: There's
some people laughing.
Tracy, do you want that one?
No?
Tracy does not wish it.
Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JOHN PALFREY: Yeah, exactly.
So if somebody in the Harvard
Library System liked it--
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN: It
would be fitting to have
the answer crowdsourced.
JOHN PALFREY: Yeah,
that's exactly--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I certainly
think that we
have catalog systems that do
allow different kinds of access
points.
And they may not be as
seductive and as appealing
as this kind of
display, but they
are initial and in some ways
rudimentary attempts to combine
digital information and
physical information
into a wide variety of indexes
that give the user lots
of ways to get into it.
The problem is they're
a little too complex.
And so we still
need to keep working
at figuring out how
to make it both simple
but complex at the same time.
JOHN PALFREY: My answer-- Tracy
knows vastly more about it
than I do, and from a
technical perspective
there are a zillion
challenges behind it.
But I think from a conceptual
perspective, the idea
that there's one indicator for
something in an old-school way,
as compared to saying you could
have many more data points that
allow different ways into it, I
think that conceptual shift is
actually very, very important.
And I think the trend,
which is moving away
from having the knowledge
be in a particular catalog
or a particular catalog entry
to one where in fact there
are many more ways to
identify the information
and then do more with it, is
sort of an obvious movement.
MARCY MURNINGHAM: My
name is Marcy Murningham,
and my question
pertains to the theme
of hybrid and collaboration.
There are vast pools of
financial assets swimming
around every community,
billions and billions of dollars
in the form of assets
under management
for tax-exempt
institutional investors.
In theory, those
tax-exempt institutions
exist to advance
the public interest.
That is the reason for
their tax-exempt status.
And Boston, as we know, is
very rich in those kinds
of institutions.
According to my research, the
top 60 tax-exempt institutions
in Boston have combined
assets of over $50 billion.
There are ways, it
seems to me, for tapping
into some of that
money and bending it
toward the public
interest-- that is to say,
institutions such as
public libraries that
otherwise rely on
taxpayer revenue streams
or even philanthropy.
I'd just encourage you
to think more creatively
about revenue sources that
could be bent toward libraries
in our nation's communities.
JOHN PALFREY: Thank you.
I think that's very thoughtful.
I would imagine that one
of those is this one,
is Harvard and others.
Also one school that has
a fair amount of capital,
not the same amount
that this one does,
but I think that's
important to note.
I think one of the
reasons why I think
it's incumbent upon
this institution
to do things like open
access, to do things
like digitize its materials
and share them more broadly,
even though there's not
a revenue stream back
to this institution,
is because I
think we are private
institutions that
have a public purpose.
And I think if we don't
see it that way we're
making a huge mistake.
Whether or not there would be
a tax on these institutions
that then goes back
to public libraries,
I'm not sure that that's
necessarily right either.
But I think that it's a
very interesting question,
and I think it's one that
we have to figure out
how we are justifying,
in a sense,
holding this amount of
capital in a relatively
small number of institutions.
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN: Over here?
ERICA CHARIS: Hi.
My name's Erica Charis,
and I'm a librarian over
at Berklee College of Music.
JOHN PALFREY: Awesome.
AUDIENCE: The ideas that
are something in my head
that I'm hoping to hear
what your thoughts are on,
if libraries are about
people and libraries
are becoming more
digital, how do
we bridge the gap
between the kid talking
into his phone and the
librarian sitting at the desk
three feet away?
What does digital service
necessarily look like?
JOHN PALFREY: That's
a great question.
I suspect many
people in the room
have great thoughts
and answers to this.
I think part of it is
actually as teachers
that we actually have
to tell that student
to go talk to that person.
We need to make that
human connection happen.
I've been teaching United
States history this year
to a group of 14 kids who
are in their junior year
of high school, and I think
one of the things you do
is assign kids to go
talk to a librarian,
and to have them
interface therefore
with all these amazing
things as part of a paper.
And I think that kind of thing
that many professors do here
at the law school
[INAUDIBLE] actually
say, in the course of working on
something you actually must go
spend time with the librarian.
I think that's actually a
really positive thing to do,
and I think it creates
connections and pathways that
are essential and
actually breaks down
what is happening, when
in the digital world
we sometimes withdraw.
Even though we think
it's more social,
sometimes we're withdrawing,
away from human contact.
So I actually
think, as educators,
in some sense we have
to construct ways
to bring people back together.
Now, could it be-- go ahead.
I would love to hear--
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN: I think
you might be about to say
what I'm going to ask you.
JOHN PALFREY: So why don't you
say what was on my mind, yes?
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN:
Suppose Apple comes to you
with a proposal for your advice.
And Apple says, you know what?
We'd like to improve
the Siri experience.
The easiest part of
Siri is to answer
the 20% of possible questions
that 80% of the people
ask, which is like,
what's the weather going
to be tomorrow or--
JOHN PALFREY: What's the
score on the Red Sox game?
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN: Exactly.
Or, I'd like to buy a book.
Maybe that won't happen.
But anyway, there's a
bunch of other questions
that are long-tail questions.
What if the way that we
used to route letters
that children wrote to Santa and
addressed to the North Pole--
and they got sent
somewhere, right?
I think they still do.
They go to people who
answer the letters?
I don't know what the
liability policy is.
But what if similar
to that, we simply
arranged for people
asking Siri to route
those two reference librarians
around the country or the world
who would then answer
through the Siri pipeline
and be attributed to it.
By the way, this is brought
to you courtesy of a library.
And if you'd like to be more
about it, blah, blah, blah.
What would your
reaction be to that?
Is that like, no, no.
That's exactly the kind
of corporate mediated
dehumanization that
I rail against.
[LAUGHTER]
Or would it be, this
is exactly the kind
of public-private partnership
that would put libraries back
at the center of the meaningful
questions people ask?
JOHN PALFREY: So I will answer
that if I can ask my friend
Yochai to answer after I
do, because he's much more
about that kind of system--
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN: Yochai
is playing the role of Siri
in this.
JOHN PALFREY: This is the
advanced cold call request
to my friend in a moment.
I was really interested-- did
you see The New York Times
article about is
Wikipedia in trouble
as the numbers are
declining and so forth?
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN: They run
that article about every year.
JOHN PALFREY: They do, but
it was in the Sunday Review
this week.
We're seeing a little
bit more serious.
It wasn't a great
article, but anyway.
So here are a couple of answers.
I would be hesitant to do that
particular deal with Apple
for the reason
you're suggesting,
which is I worry that
if what we keep doing
is creating systems
that do not have
the library as the
primary interface,
whether it's a public
library or a research library
or a special library or a school
library, I am troubled by that.
So the deal with Apple makes
me nervous for a really, really
simple reason--
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN: So the
model is free to all, so long
as you come through our doorway.
JOHN PALFREY: Right.
Well, so long as you
don't necessarily
have to come through
Apple's doorway, right?
So if it were done in a
truly open source way,
I could imagine that
being very attractive.
If it's only
through Siri or it's
creating a system
that relies upon Siri
and the iPhone as opposed to an
Android device or [INAUDIBLE].
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN:
You could imagine
it building into the DPLA
as part of that stack
and have an API call
to ask a librarian,
and Siri can plug in, and
Google Now can plug in.
JOHN PALFREY: That would be
much more interesting, for sure.
But I wouldn't do a deal--
and I just think of Apple
as the ultimate in
exclusive-- somebody
has written about
this too, as have you.
So yes, but only according to a
structure that was truly open.
One thing that we've talked
a lot about with DPLA
that's a fun idea
which is like this
is the idea of the scannebago.
I don't know if people
have heard this idea,
but it's called the scannebago.
I did not come up with it.
Emily Gore who
works at DPLA did.
But the idea of the scannebago--
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN:
He's making Emily Gore
be the recipient of the
trademark infringement letter.
JOHN PALFREY: No, no.
The idea of the scannebago
would be to get a Winnebago
and put in the back
of it a scanner
and drive it around the country
and have people bring out
the materials that
they have to scan them,
and then the people
who were driving it
would help put in the
metadata and do the scanning.
And you could imagine the
documentary or the NPR piece
sort of writes
itself, this notion
of driving around the country.
And you could imagine it tapping
into library students, people
who just care about libraries,
the sort of Wikipedia
equivalents.
You could see it also really
appealing to retired librarians
as something that people could
do as part of this network.
And I actually think about
when reference librarians
retire, what are some
of the things that
would be really fun to do?
It might be occasionally to be
in this particular role, which
I think the DPLA
actually could mediate
in a really interesting way.
So I think there is
a version of what
has made Wikipedia so successful
that we could do for libraries.
It'd be really,
really fun frankly.
You think about Wikimania
coming to a place
like this, as it did
a bunch of years ago.
Having DPLA Fest be a place
where people showed up
and actually edited metadata
and answered questions.
It would be really--
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN: It's like
a collective Antiques Roadshow
content.
JOHN PALFREY: Yes, incredibly
geeky and incredibly fun.
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN:
But there'd be
a triage area at
the beginning to see
if there's a copyright problem.
JOHN PALFREY: Well,
there could be that, too.
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN: You'd
turn away a lot of stuff.
JOHN PALFREY: That
could be true, too.
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN: These
Hardy Boys are too young.
JOHN PALFREY: [INAUDIBLE]
risk with respect
to the copyright, which would
be an interesting conversation.
Y
JOHN PALFREY: Are
you willing to--
YOCHAI BENKLER: Jet lag
from being away for awhile
notwithstanding, I'll try.
Something that came out in the
exchange between the two of you
and the scannebago
is let's not talk
about the corporate
culture of Apple and Siri.
Let's talk about the
isolation of the interaction
with the machine.
And you had said
something earlier
about the human
experience of the library.
You talked about
the kids coming.
And as you start to talk
about the scannebago
and who would come
and who wouldn't come,
I'd love to hear more from you
about what the human platform
element is, which is quite
distinct from the DPLA
platform, is much
more like that,
and is a form of a response to
the Siri question that's about.
Even if it were fine from
the corporate perspective,
it takes the service
aspect of the library
and makes it available
to isolated individuals.
And the question is, can
you say a little bit more,
either from the book or your
experience with how you're
thinking about building
the library at your school,
about what it is that we do to
support that human interaction
that libraries
traditionally have provided,
and how that
connects, if at all,
to this very powerful response
you began with Martha's
question of, don't
need a business model,
you need a story about the
core of the public service
and about the core
of human interaction?
Can you put a little bit
more flesh on those bones?
JOHN PALFREY: So this is what
happens when you hang out
with your old professors.
They answer your question
with a hard question back.
I totally didn't miss that
that's what just happened.
I was hoping to glean some of
the brilliance of Yochai in it,
but we got it in
a different form.
So thank you.
So the hard question, I
think, is an important one.
So step one, from
my perspective,
is the notion of
humanity, which is
I actually think that
if we lose the notion
of the incredible, incredible
group of people who work
in libraries-- this is where
the love letter starts--
and the experience of somebody
walking in-- whether it's
a scholar or it's a kid or it's
an old person, whatever it is--
that is a hugely
important, I think,
democratic interaction
that actually doesn't have
to do with the transaction.
It doesn't have to do with
the transaction in the sense
of Netflix wants you to think
about this movie instead
of this movie.
It has to do with
people in a community
supporting one another and
doing what is civic work.
So there's something that's
just essential about that.
And no matter how quickly we
hurtle towards the digital,
I want to be sure
that that humanity is
in the mix in a
really fundamental way
and that we don't lose it.
So that is really,
really crucial to it.
Your question, though, also
goes to what is the role
of the librarian going forward.
I would say in the
tough love category
in this book is actually
saying to my friends who
work in libraries and
others that I actually
think the shift we have to
make is to see librarians
as not necessarily working
for a single institution
so much as working in the public
grid in a networked way, right?
So there are about
100,000 school libraries
in the United States.
There are, call it,
15,000 public libraries
and call it another 10,000
or 15,000 other kinds
of libraries.
So we're talking about
more than 100,000,
but not 150,000, institutions.
To the extent that each
of these institutions
had some percentage--
if it's one person
or it's a percentage
of somebody's time--
which is really devoted to this
network public effort, I think,
would be vastly more powerful
than as isolated institutions.
And I realize that's a shift.
That would be
saying to the dean,
you're paying for people to
be focused on your professor,
supporting the professor writing
this great book on cooperation
or whatever it might
be-- you actually
have to divert a certain
percentage of that
to something that
is the public good.
And by the way, it
will boomerang back
in really awesome ways.
And actually, this
is a bad example
because I think this dean has
made exactly that enlightened
decision at Harvard Law School.
But I think if every library
were seeing itself in that way,
I think that could
be very powerful.
I think there are lots of
librarians in this room who
actually lived that experience.
But I'm not positive that that's
exactly what every institution
sees itself as doing as every
town library, every school
library, and so forth.
But I think that
networked approach
could be enormously
powerful in ways
that we haven't yet experienced.
And I feel like it's taking
some of the learning that
has made the exposure
on the web so exciting
and the kinds of things that
have developed from that,
and having that
apply in the library
space for all these
amazing principles all
this amazing
material that I think
is so exciting for
what could come.
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN: In both
the book and the presentation,
you've managed to kind
of capture your optimism
without being
pollyannish about really
what's so valuable about the
library and the community
it represents.
But you also manage
to put in at least
two potential snakes
in the gardens that
are really worrisome.
You did a little riff on
what we'd call the first sale
doctrine that says the anchor,
the platform of that library,
for hundreds of years
has been the idea
that once you've got
the physical artifact,
you can lend it to someone
else, which also became
the anchor of the
physical community
because you had to go to the
library to fetch the book.
So much of just that
lending is part of it.
And you pointed out that
a bizarre paradox, but not
a necessary one, about
digital advancements
is, congratulations, now we have
a way of locking this stuff up
tight where I might have a
privilege if I could figure out
how to unlock it, but I can't
figure it out and unlocking it
itself may break the law.
So that seems like one
snake in the garden.
I just wanted to see, if
you follow the dotted line,
do we end up with more
and more stuff locked up
as fewer and fewer of these get
produced, because the economics
are just so simple?
You also said at the end, these
might be interesting artifacts,
but they're not going to be
mass-produced the way they
are even still today.
And the second snake in the
garden is how you find stuff,
that previously the
way to find stuff
was through categorizations
done by librarians
who had professional ethics
and responsibilities about how
to order stuff and
truly try to make
it accessible without wondering
about who paid them for product
placement on the shelf?
And now, as you say,
again and again we're
going to Google, one in
a handful of companies,
for all information,
not just monographs.
Follow that dotted line out,
and do you see any difference
from the trend that's
already kind of overcome us
of not going to the library
or the library system
for that kind of categorization?
Those two snakes in the garden,
if that's what they are--
what do you do about them?
JOHN PALFREY: I think that
is a very good summation,
and maybe that's where
we should end so people
can go do something else.
But I think--
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN: They're
going to [INAUDIBLE] next door
while eating.
JOHN PALFREY: I'm so
glad. [INAUDIBLE].
That's good, since this is
a celebration of libraries.
No.
I think those two
snakes in the grass,
as they went their way
through, are huge risks.
We didn't talk about the entire
mass of the rest of copyright
and the difficulty
of doing something
like DPLA given the
strictures of copyright,
so I think that's more like
an elephant in the room
than a snake in the grass.
It's so obvious.
But I think these
two, the notion
of the absence of a
digital first sale doctrine
and the requirement that
libraries increasingly
become leasers as opposed
to owners-- when you combine
that with the sort of
general corporatization--
this is something that
goes back to the earliest
days of the internet, and
what James Boyle and Yochai
and others who are writing
about the enclosure movement.
I think those are things,
those are lessons,
that we've learned in other
parts of our scholarship
that we have to apply over
here in the world of libraries,
and actually seek to
bend the arc of where
the future will go,
or the future that
will be history will go.
I think that's a really,
really important thing for us
to stand up and say, we
don't want that version
of what the future could hold.
And one of the reasons
we don't want that
is because I think it
will undermine support
for libraries.
And I think if we undermine
support for libraries
and we don't support them
in the way that we should,
I think that will
undermine our democracy
and I think it will undermine
scholarship, which of course,
are not unrelated also.
And so yes, I think
those two snakes
making their way through
the grass are worrisome.
I don't know how to meld
the elephant stomping around
with snakes.
You're better at these
metaphors than I am.
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN: No, I was
just thinking of a Mark Twain
quote, that everybody always
talks about the weather
but nobody ever does
anything about it.
And John, you're a great
example of somebody
who is both talking
about the environment
that we're in, and not
just remarking upon it
but building the
actual structures,
the roles you've played in each
of these examples-- of course,
something you wouldn't
naturally trumpet.
But you have just been so
crucial to all of this.
And for those reasons, it's not
just what you're writing about
but what you're
doing that we are
so lucky to have you in the
mix, and all of the things
that you've done for us.
So if you'll allow us
the uncomfortable moment
of thanking you for
all your hard work.
JOHN PALFREY: You're very kind.
Thank you, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
And thank you to
the Berkman Center
and to the Harvard Law
School Library for hosting.
I look forward to
seeing you next door.
Thank you.
JONATHAN ZITTRAIN: Thank you.